- Give me that Kardashian tea,
and I ain't talkin' about gossip.
(beat drop music)
(whooshing and squeaking)
(sipping)
(beat drop music)
I am going to try a two-week tea detox.
I don't really know what
the fuck that means,
but I'm here.
- I've seen this trend
all over my Instagram.
- Kim Kardashian's endorsed it.
All these celebrity
models have endorsed it.
So, it's like their bodies look great,
but is it the tea or is
it the personal chefs
and their trainers that they
all have money to afford.
- Fit Tea and Me, just eating garbage
and living my garbage life-style,
probably isn't gonna help that much.
Maybe it'll be a life-style change.
Maybe I'll start hiking more
and other things fit people do.
- We'll see if it actually
holds up to its label.
- Ah. It's very light.
- (Laughing) Isn't that what I do?
They're always like very light.
- Supports metabolism, boosts energy,
and reduces bloating.
It's not approved by the FDA.
Awesome.
- Let's get a whiff of this bad boy.
- Oh. Woo-hoo.
Do not put that close to your nose.
That is strong, but it smells really good.
- Wow. Look at that.
This shit is straight out
of Beverly Hills, honey.
- Feel like I'm gonna take a sip
and immediately feel my bowels moving.
- Here we go.
This is for you, Kim.
- You can definitely taste the lemon.
- It's got a lot of zest, lemon
and it just has a very strong aroma.
- Tea is just better than having coffee
with cream and sugar every morning.
- Hopefully, I'll have a
Kardashian body by the end of this.
- (whispering) It's tea time.
(water gurgling)
Ahh.
(silly music)
- I'm drinking my first cup of Fit Tea,
and honestly, I'm pretty into it.
It's exactly like coffee.
It's waking me up.
It's maybe the placebo effect.
- I would drink it
consistently in the morning.
I just felt like it gave me
a kick start to my morning.
I was super energized.
- So, I just drank the tea,
and surprisingly I feel
really awake right now.
And my heart's beating really fast,
and I don't know if it's
supposed to do that. (laughs)
- I have to say, I didn't
do it in the morning,
and I just did it in the afternoon,
and I have an extra spunk in my step.
- I've noticed that I'm really tired
and just very low energy,
and the thing was advertised
as a energy booster.
- [Kirsten] So, this is Fit Tea.
- Only tea can't just make you fit.
Are you dieting and exercising, also?
- [Kirsten] No. I'm not.
- Okay.
- I literally throughout
the day would have
to remind myself make
sure you eat your dinner
on the way home.
It's like, why am I not hungry?
- I think the thing
that confuses me most is
by celebrities' tea pictures,
like this,
and they don't even drink it probably.
- It's my second week on the Tea,
and it's already suppressed my appetite.
I'm not that hungry and it's noon.
It tastes very potent.
I love the aroma of the Tea,
but it's just definitely not somethin'
that I'd want to drink everyday.
- I really miss coffee.
- My last Fit Tea.
(whispering) So over it.
- I drank Fit Tea for two weeks,
and literally nothing happened.
- I am Nick Guillory.
And I do not endorse this product.
You see this?
I'm literally the same size.
- I think that regular
green tea will suffice
just as well as Fit Tea.
I don't really see a difference.
- I mean, I've been pooping
two to three times a day.
I don't know if it's related to this.
- I did feel like I was
going to the bathroom more,
which isn't ideal to
drink and then go to work,
because your just with
all your co-workers,
and your stomach's a rumblin'.
- Overall, it's not that special.
It's not like a magic
tea or anything. (laughs)
(silly music)
(whooshing and squeaking)
(fun music)